- One of the scariest parts
that sort of came out of Covid
was that if you were accused
of spreading misinformation,
and misinformation
was narrowly defined
as Covid misinformation,
but now it's defined more
broadly into any misinformation.
And so, reproductive
health in the wake
of Roe v. Wade falling,
if you are spreading
misinformation
about reproductive health,
your license is at risk.
And so I wrote a piece
for "The Spectator"
about the fall of Roe v.
Wade and all these things,
and no one would talk to me on
the record because they said,
"I can lose my license."
And who defines misinformation
and who makes these decisions?
All of it is secret.
And so I can just get a
letter one day that says
I've had my license revoked.
And so, all of
this is permeating
through licensing for
psychiatry, for medical.
To get into med school you
have to answer questions,
you know, it's a litmus test.
How will you implement DEI
in your professional life
as a medical
professional of any kind?
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today are
the authors of the new book,
"Stolen Youth: How Radicals
Are Erasing Innocence
and Indoctrinating
A Generation",
Karol Markowicz
and Bethany Mandel.
Karol, Bethany, welcome
to "The Rubin Report".
- Thank you.
- Karol, this must
be freaking you out
because we usually
do this over Skype
or in person when we're drunk.
But here we are sober
in the middle of the day
talking about stuff.
- Hard to not fix my hair
and look at myself, you know.
(Dave laughing)
- And Bethany, we've
never met before.
- No, no.
- But you're in the
mix of these mothers
who are fighting this lunacy.
- Yeah, I just tag along
with Karol, basically.
- How did you guys decide
to write a book together?
- I'll go to the
new person first.
I'm gonna have to blend this,
I don't wanna cause a
cat fight here, right?
- Obviously, obviously, yeah.
(Bethany laughing)
- So, Karol and I have been
friends for a really long time.
It's hard to do,
but we're friends.
And we have very
similar worldviews,
and she writes the columns
that I always meant to write
but didn't get around
to emailing the editor,
and then I'd read
it and I'm like,
"Dang, she did that
better than I would've."
And so, we'd been talking
about it for years.
And we had another iteration
of the book proposal,
"Get Your Village
Off My Children",
and then Covid hit.
Everything froze
and we sort of said,
"Let's see where
the dust settles."
And then the dust
settled and we realized,
"Wow, 'Get Your Village
Off My Children' is legit.
We really need to get them
away from our children."
And so we said,
"There is this woke stuff
happening younger and younger,
but do we have
enough for a book?
Is there enough material here?"
And so we started a Google Doc,
and we just started
dumping stuff in.
And we realized after a
week, we have too much stuff.
The problem isn't,
is there a book?
It's like, how can we only
write one book about this,
and how do we narrow this down?
And so, we just
started plugging.
I don't know how
much you wanna say,
but do you wanna take over
this part of the story?
- Yeah, sure.
- Well, let me maybe do
a little bio part first
before we get fully to that
- Yeah, sorry.
- just so that people have
a frame of reference here.
Why don't you both say how
many kids you have, ages,
things like that, that kind of
frame this in a personal way.
- So, Bethany Mandel,
I am a columnist for "Deseret
News" and "Fox News".
I write things, places.
- You're on Twitter?
- Yeah, I do the tweets.
And I'm an editor of a
children's book series
that is super patriotic
and wonderful called,
"Heroes Of Liberty".
And I have six kids,
aged nine and under.
- Six, nine and under?
- Six, yeah.
- I just met the two-month-old.
- Yeah, he's really cute.
- My God,
you're really going for it.
- Yeah.
- Karol.
- I'm Karol Markowicz.
I'm a columnist at the "New
York Post" and "Fox News",
and I have only three kids,
which seems like a lot
until you meet Bethany.
- As someone with two,
three does seem like a lot.
- You gotta catch up, really.
- So, you guys, you get
this Google Doc going
and your dumping stuff in there.
Trust me, I wish I could
wake up on any given day
and have no woke
thing to go crazy over
so I can see how
this thing would be
expanding and expanding.
And then, how did you
decide to frame it
sort of purely around education?
And was that just from being
moms and you were like,
"This is clearly the
thing that matters most."?
- So we have two different
paths that we have taken.
I have kids in public
and private schools.
I have two sons in public
and a daughter in private,
and Bethany homeschools.
And so what we were
seeing was during Covid
kids were just
the last priority.
They just completely
weren't considered.
They would post re-opening plans
and not even put
children in them.
They had to live
under restrictions
far longer than anybody else.
And we saw that it was really
getting to be a problem
where kids were just not
considered in society at all.
And so our book focuses on that,
but also on how schools
are targeting them
and publishing companies and
libraries and doctor's offices,
all of it targeting for
woke indoctrination.
- Are you shocked at
the amount of parents
that just go along with whatever
crazy thing happens next?
I mean, I can tell you as
a father of a six-month-old
and a four-month-old,
the idea that, you know,
is it the CDC or the NIH now,
they wanna put in the schedule
the Covid vaccination
for six-month-olds.
There's no chance in hell!
Literally, over my dead body.
But they do things and then
people just go along with it.
Was that shocking to see,
or is that just
kind of Parent 101?
- No, it's actually the
opposite of Parent 101.
- Not what Parent 101 should be.
I mean, the way it
functions, maybe.
- What you're supposed to do
is lay your life on the line
and do anything possible
to save your children,
to help your children in
any way, shape, or form.
And what we saw over
Covid, I'm sorry,
but was a lot of parents saying,
"Well, I don't wanna
be the loudmouth.
I don't wanna be
the troublemaker."
And so they went along with it.
One of the craziest things
that happened over Covid,
and our book isn't
just about Covid,
there's so, so much more to it.
But, this sort of
drove it home for me.
Last summer, summer of '22.
Right, that was '22?
- Mm hm, yes.
- Yeah.
- (laughs)It's going
faster and faster.
- It really is.
I sent my kids to a
violin summer camp.
Signed them up, first day of
summer camp I dropped them off
and every single kid
was wearing a mask.
And I thought, "Gosh,
that's awfully weird."
Didn't think anything of it.
I got a call from the camp,
"We're requiring masks."
And I was completely shocked.
There's no mask
mandate in the county,
no mask mandate in the
park that they're in.
We're past masks, why
are you requiring masks
only for the summer
camp at this park?
And they said, "Well, it's
to protect the children."
As if my biggest imperative
isn't to protect my children.
And I came in guns
blazing, furious.
And I pulled my kids out and
they said, "Sorry, no refund."
And I said, "Oh, you do not
know who you're dealing with."
(all laughing)
- Yeah, yeah.
- Do you?
And I said, "I want the name
of your board of directors,
I want all of their
contact information,
and let's have a conversation
about how this bait and
switch situation happened,
and about how you
have no concern
about the future of children
and the wellbeing of children."
Why was I the only parent
that was horrified?
Every other parent
dropped their kid off
dutifully in a mask for a music
camp in the middle of summer
in a literal swamp.
We call DC the swamp for
a reason, it is a swamp.
And every single parent just
said, "You know, this is-"
And I had a lot of
work to do that week.
I had piled all the rest
of my work that summer,
including for this
book, into that week.
And I pulled my
kids out and I said,
"Okay, looks like I'm
not sleeping this week."
And I did mommy camp
with them the whole week,
and from 7:00 PM until
2:00 AM I worked.
And I don't understand
why more parents
didn't take that perspective.
- So Karol, you were,
I know this factually,
you were dealing with
this nonsense in Brooklyn
and the crazy things they were
putting your kids through.
What was the snap point for you?
- Well, the snap point was
I saw that nothing
was getting better.
But just for a slight
defense of parents,
I would say that Covid
ran in to cancel culture
in such a way that
parents were afraid
of having their lives
destroyed if they spoke out
and if they spoke up.
And while that doesn't
excuse anybody,
they should still be pulling
their kids out of camps
and doing stuff like that.
It does explain why parents
didn't fight harder at the time.
People did get fired for saying,
"This school should open."
- And we all pick our battles.
We all pick our battles.
Did I mask my kids at moments
that I did not feel
comfortable with?
Absolutely, I did.
But, that summer of
2022 really killed me.
- Right.
A little bit past the point
where any of this made sense.
And I think many people would
argue it never made sense,
and that's a whole other thing.
So when you would
talk to other parents,
when you do this
at the violin camp
or now you're talking to
parents at your kids' schools,
was it really just fear,
or is it just that people
actually had no freaking clue?
Like, in some ways
they're not adults.
Something like that.
We have a Gen X
generation of people
that never fully became adults.
- It was a combination.
In Brooklyn. I had people
who were just like,
"Well, the CDC says.
And if the CDC
says, then I do it.
And the doctors say."
(Dave laughing)
And I would be like, "No, the
doctors don't really say."
But then there were
people who would tell me,
"I agree with you,
but I can't speak up."
And that was really
terrifying to me.
We opened with a chapter on
the history of
totalitarian societies
and how this has
happened before,
this forced conformity
has happened before.
And it's happening here now,
and it's really scary to watch.
I know you mentioned
this in your book,
"Don't Burn This
Country", which I read.
- Great book, great book.
- Yeah, a really good book.
But the conformity thing,
and people feel like
they have to say
exactly the right thing
in the exact right way,
really scared people off
from doing the right
thing for their kids.
Again, no excuse.
- I was canceled over Covid,
so I really have nothing.
- She was a grandma killer.
- What were you canceled for?
- Grandma killer.
- Oh, you were
a grandma Killer?
I see you always fighting
with people on Twitter,
- I am always
fighting with people.
- What were you canceled over.
- So in May of 2020, I said,
"What's the endpoint here?
What's the end game?
What are we doing?"
I'm not willing to have
every single aspect
of our society sacrificed
when the pediatric
wing of our hospital,
I mean, this was so
representative of everything.
The pediatric wing
of our local hospital
was converted into a Covid
ward and sat empty for a year.
And so if you had a kid
who needed to go to the ER,
you had to go farther away.
And, you know, tough luck.
"We gotta keep it
open just in case
there's enough Covid
patients to fill it."
And I did that and I trended
on Twitter for a full day.
And there are family members
that still won't
see us to this day.
And we were talking
before the show about
how all of this stuff
impacts our kids.
Like, my kids will never see
some family members again.
- Yeah.
Well, being on this show is
not gonna help that department
because now you're gonna
have members of my family
that won't talk to you either.
- Just add them to the list.
- It's okay.
What about the professional
class related to all of this?
So, talking about the teacher
class and the administrators,
whether it's at a
school or at a hospital,
were any of them
trying to fight too?
- So part of the problem is that
the people who give
them their licensing,
doctors, for example,
or teachers colleges,
are very leftists
and they teach them
how to be indoctrinators.
And I think Bethany could
speak more to the licensing
'cause she wrote the
chapter on it in our book.
- Yeah.
So one of the scariest parts
that sort of came out of Covid
was that if you were accused
of spreading misinformation,
and misinformation
was narrowly defined
as Covid misinformation,
but now it's defined more
broadly into any misinformation.
And so, reproductive
health in the wake of
Roe v. Wade falling,
if you are spreading
misinformation
about reproductive health,
your license is at risk.
And so I wrote a piece
for "The Spectator"
about the fall of Roe v.
Wade and all these things,
and no one would talk to me on
the record because they said,
"I can lose my license."
And who defines misinformation
and who makes these decisions?
All of it is secret.
And so I can just get a
letter one day that says
I've had my license revoked.
And so all of this is
permeating through licensing
for psychiatry, for medical.
To get into med school you
have to answer questions,
you know, it's a litmus test.
How will you implement DEI
in your professional life
as a medical
professional of any kind?
- Which basically means kill
more White people, right?
At some level, right?
If you want equity in health.
- Well, we saw with
the Covid vaccinations.
The first priority in,
which state was it?
- It was California.
- I think Oregon did it too,
or maybe the city of
Portland or something.
- So, you didn't get it first
if you were a White male.
Tough luck, gotta wait.
- Well, in actuality, it
was probably pretty good.
But,
- Fair.
- that wasn't the intention.
What about the psychological
level for your kids?
'Cause I remember at the
height of Covid craziness,
I hadn't seen my family
in like six months,
I was like, "Forget this.
I'm going back to New York
just to see my parents
and see my nieces and nephews."
And I go into my nephew's room,
and I think he was in
sixth grade at the time,
maybe fifth grade.
And he's got a computer
and he's in school.
But he was also playing on his
Switch and doing his thing.
And I was like, "Ian,
what's the deal with this?"
And he's like, "It's so stupid.
Everybody knows it's stupid,
nobody's paying attention."
In the most pure,
innocent possible way.
But the way they destroyed kids.
- Absolutely.
The anxiety rates
are off the charts.
The suicide rates
are higher than ever.
So many things that they did
that we just will never have
any kind of recourse for.
But yeah, what you described
was a really damaging era
in the lives of children
that they'll never get back.
That's it.
That childhood moment is gone.
I think part of it is,
and going back to
that force conformity,
it's a way of dividing us.
It's like, "What's a woman?
We don't even know
what this means.
These are words that
have no meaning."
It's a way of making
sure that we stay divided
and don't unite over anything
so that they can
keep us in control,
and that they can keep
the kids indoctrinated.
- Yeah, yeah.
And again, this goes
way past just Covid.
But Covid was a
great accelerator for
all of this stuff.
And, you know, you can't
revolutionize an entire society
when everyone is
happy and content.
- [Karol] Exactly.
(Dave laughing)
- And so, the misery and the
anxiety and the depression
of all of these
kids is the goal,
because that's how
you further change.
Because they see that
stuff is messed up
and they need to fix it.
And so, you know, who cares if
they lose a couple in the end
to justify the means?
- Yeah, well that's why I do
believe it's intentional now.
- Yeah, it's intentional.
- I used to try my best,
and I still do to some degree,
to not go after
everybody's motives.
You, I think, moved here a
day before I did to Florida,
right?
Or the day me?
- We're so smart.
- We're right there, right?
We landed probably within
24 hours of each other.
Upend our lives, come
here, now you're here.
Your kids are going to school.
There's no chance they're
gonna be masked or forced.
That changes
literally everything.
- And again, it's
not just the masking,
because apparently we're
past Covid, Joe Biden says.
- Not for that emergency order,
still got that 'till May.
- It's still going, yeah.
- We've got Covid 25.
- Right, It's coming.
But, the whole Ron DeSantis
not allowing woke
nonsense in schools,
which means that my kids
who are in public school,
I feel safer with
them at those schools
and I don't worry
about them as much.
They don't have 12
trans friends each
because it just hasn't
hit here in the same way
that it hit New York.
But, the thing that
we always say is
that you shouldn't
feel safe and confident
if you live in a red area.
It's coming to you too.
The teachers go to
the teachers colleges
where they learn marxism,
which they pass along
to your children.
This is happening everywhere.
We heard from people in
small towns, in rural areas,
in deep red states, and
they were all saying,
"My kids are getting it too."
- What do you say is
the ultimate answer
to this at the school level?
I mean, is it pure school
choice and funding students
instead of systems and doing
the homeschooling thing?
Is it basically obliterating
education as we know it?
- We have different paths.
But, you talk about yours first.
- So we homeschool and
I have no intention
of doing otherwise.
I mean, I don't
live in a red state.
I live in the most liberal
county in a quite liberal state.
I live Montgomery
County, Maryland.
- Why has Montgomery
County gone so bananas?
Every time I see
something outta Montgomery
it's beyond woke.
- It's nuts and bananas.
Part of it is because
a lot of us journalist
folks live there.
- Aah, that's it.
Because it's Maryland, it
shouldn't be that crazy, right?
- So the stories that
we are getting published
on "Fox News", and I have
a hand in a lot of them,
a lot of the stuff
that gets published
I'm feeding to people
because it's not my zone,
but I want it out there.
And it's because I have
the privilege of having
the email address of
a "Fox News" reporter.
There's people in
Indiana and in Oklahoma
who don't have that privilege,
doesn't mean it's
not happening there.
And so, for us, we homeschool
and we are very choosy about
the friends that our kids have.
But my DM's on Twitter
are a repository
of all of the
crazy MCPS stories.
But what's really sort of crazy
is that they are
so open about it,
they're so proud about it.
And so a lot of the stuff
that I end up passing on
to "Fox News" reporters is stuff
that they've posted publicly
on their own Twitter feeds.
- Well, it's sort of like
Libs of TikTok, right?
- Yes, exactly.
- People are like, "Oh, she's
attacking these people."
But literally she's
reposting their own videos.
So how do you differ
in terms of that?
I mean, you're
not homeschooling.
- So, my kids are at
public and private
and we really lay
the line down at home
that this is what we believe
and these are the values
that we want you to
carry out into the world.
And so a lot of it requires
being really honest
with our children about our
beliefs because parents say,
"Oh, we don't really talk
with our kids about that."
Well we don't talk about
necessarily politics.
We don't talk to them about
which political candidates we
like or anything like that.
But we do talk to them about
values, and that's important.
You wanna get the
message to your kids
and you wanna lay the
foundation for them
because a lot of the time
you will have to let
them go eventually.
They will get to college and
they'll face this wokeness
no matter how much
you've protected them.
And it's important that they
know where they came from.
- Yeah.
And I not just tell
them but also live it.
They watched me scream
at Montgomery County
Council on Zoom meetings.
And I would sit there for
an hour and 45 minutes,
and they never tell
you your time slot
for speaking for
two minutes on Zoom,
so you have to sit there.
And so there's one video of
me holding one of my babies
and they turn on the camera
and I was the first one
testifying for this portion
of the County Council Bill.
And so I just let loose and
started screaming at them.
And my kids at the
end of it were like,
"First of all,
you're terrifying.
I do not
wanna get on your bad side."
- "We're not going
to homeschool tomorrow."
- They sort of avoided me
for the next four hours.
But they saw that I was
screaming about them,
I was yelling at them about
how kids were being treated,
about how my son was
yelled at in a supermarket
because he wasn't
wearing a mask.
Just because I'll play along
to go into the supermarket
doesn't mean I'm gonna
pick my kids to do it.
And so my kid got yelled at in
the supermarket, and I said,
"This is your fault,
Montgomery County Public.",
the County Council.
And they saw I was
fighting for them,
and that is really powerful.
And they got it.
The front lawn sign for
the school board candidate
that we were supporting,
that was not just for my kids
who are not in
the public school,
but it's for, literally,
our neighbors kids.
Because the woke infestation
isn't just impacting
sort of all of this
ideological indoctrination,
but it's also impacting
the quality of education
that's happening
in these schools.
At the elementary
school around the corner
my daughter would be in
fourth grade in that school,
less than 5% of kids are
performing on level in math,
and I think 7% in English.
I mean, your famous tagline-
- Every minute spent on wokeness
is not spent on math
or reading or science.
It's a time suck
from those subjects.
- Isn't that the
extraordinary part of this?
Whenever I give a
speech about this stuff
I always say to people,
"Picture your third
grade teacher.
Now picture that woman,
it's most likely a woman,
at least if you're
of a certain age,
picture that woman talking
about sex with you."
It's so insane when I
picture Mrs. Kochenour,
who I thought was
120, she was maybe 55,
but I just thought she
was the oldest thing ever,
and she read us "Secret Garden.
The idea that she would've
secretly, in a small room,
been talking to me, "Maybe
your penis is a vagina."
It's so bananas, and
yet, I'm not that old.
That's 30 something years ago.
- Well, the secrecy
is a big part of it.
Another thing that I
like like to say is that
leftism is very unpopular.
Only 7% of the country considers
themselves very liberal.
So that means that 93% don't.
And that 93% is the
majority, obviously,
but also they don't
feel like the majority
because that 7% is so loud
and they do what they
do through force,
and they kind of push
their way into our society.
And that 93% has to realize
that they can stand
up and fight them.
- When you have
moments like that,
like the Zoom thing or
something goes viral,
and blah, blah blah,
I assume, alright,
you're gonna get a ton of hate.
And every now and again
you repost some of the hate
and they say rather
unpleasant things about you.
- They do.
- But, I'm sure your
inbox also blows up
with a lot of parents that
are like, "Thank you."
- It's also a lot.
- Do they wanna get involved,
or they just want
to encourage you
to keep fighting for them?
Because I used to
get a lot of that
when I was leaving the left.
It was like people
didn't wanna do it
but they wanted to encourage
me to keep taking the bullets,
which at some point
starts getting annoying.
- Gets old, yeah.
- And then you start resenting
those people in a weird way
because it's like you're
not superman or superwoman.
- Yeah, I mean,
people would ask me,
"How can we get the
masks off in the schools?
How can I switch?"
And my answer is,
"Switch daycares."
And they were just, "Well,
it's really convenient,
and it's close to my office."
Okay.
That's your bed and you've
decided to lie in it.
- Or fight.
But, emailing me
doesn't do anything.
- [Bethany] Exactly, exactly.
- I actually don't
run your daycare.
I would take off
the masks if I did.
You know, you have to stand
up and you have to fight.
Parenting is not easy,
as you might know.
- Do you know how many times
they pee during the day?
- They pee a lot.
- Just pee,
forget the poop thing,
it's just a lot.
- Yeah, they do pee a lot.
But, you know, the the thing is
that you're going to have to
stand up for your children,
and if you don't
stand up for them
they're going to be influenced
outside of your sphere
and you will lose them.
It happens all the time.
- And it's all of this work of
getting peed on for 18 years
goes out the window.
- Yeah, completely. (laughs)
- What's easier?
- I'm like, "Listen, if
you're gonna pee on me,
at least you're gonna
take some of my ideas
with me into life."
I would hope.
- That's the goal.
- Where are you at
now in terms of,
do you think that the
7% versus the 93%,
are things changing?
I know we have our
very microcosm version
of it in Florida,
which feels very
disconnected, as I said.
And the thing we did the
other day with the governor,
it's like, my show I do all of
the craziness for a half hour
and then I finish up with 15
minutes of Florida sanity.
So I have this huge at odds
view of the world at the moment.
- Well, Dave and I are
obviously in Florida la la land
where everything really
is so much saner.
- Do you know we live in Florida
and it's really great place.
- I know, I heard.
- We're here right now, you
don't have to go home today.
- I've written like
- You can stay here.
- one or two hundred
pieces about it.
But, I am so happy about that,
and I feel so much more
comfortable with the kids
because I don't worry
about them as much.
In the book I write a lot about
the Florida move, obviously,
and in the acknowledgements
I thank the governor
and the first lady for giving
us this place of normalcy.
And what I say in my chapter
about what to do about
this wokeness is,
you might have to move, you
might have to switch states,
you might have to
switch communities.
Maybe it's as easy
as switching schools,
but you have to do
this for your kids.
The last word in the book is
fight, and we really mean it.
You have to fight
for your children.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, do I have hope?
I have hope for our kids.
Like, our kids.
Yours too.
Sure, I've never met them.
Presumably they're okay.
- Yeah, they seem alright
so far, you know?
He's starting to
babble a little bit.
- Yeah, I mean, my nine
year old's gonna marry
her 10 year old, so we're
really in it for the long haul.
- We gotta line 'em up.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's good.
But, I mean, I am encouraged
that a lot of parents
were horrified over Covid, not
just over Covid, obviously,
but also, they got a peak at
what their kids were learning
and they were not
happy about it.
And I think that test scores
hitting the news is good
and I think that people
are recoiling more and more
in horror at those things.
But, we cover a lot
of things in the book
that people don't
really know about.
The medical chapter, to me,
was one of the most
terrifying to write.
There's so many instances,
in big ways and small ways,
that this woke
infestation, I mean,
we talked about it a little
bit with the licensing,
with med school applications.
At a conference for
neonatal doctors
they canceled a panel
that was supposed to
sort of teach doctors about
the latest technology for
- [Karol] Premature.
- Premature, thank you.
Premature babies, and
they canceled the panel
because there weren't enough
women and people of color
on the panel.
So, given the choice
between educating doctors
in the latest technology
or being woke,
they decided to be woke.
And so, all of these
things have an impact
on medical innovation, and it
doesn't end in a good place.
So, that's the stuff
that scares me.
And also in the children's
literature space,
it is so crazy now, and
getting crazier and crazier.
This was one of the things
that I talk about in the book.
I talked to librarians and
editors at big publishing houses
and they said, "The
incentive is to go woke
because the library
is buying us in bulk
and individual families
only buy us single books."
So, you know, this is the
situation that we have.
And people assume that when
they're in a doctor's office
they're safe, or if they're
reading they're safe,
and you can't assume anymore.
- Where do you think the
media plays into this?
Because even with what's
going on now with DeSantis
going after the AP African
American Studies course
because it was teaching
gender/queer theory.
And did you know that
Harriet Tubman was running
a underground lesbian bar?
- I did.
- I mean, it's all so stupid.
But the way they
frame everything
is so profoundly dishonest.
Parents watch "The View"
and they hear them say,
"Okay, they're not gonna
teach slavery in Florida."
And it's like this systemic,
everybody's word systemic,
but it's like this
systemic stupidening.
Stupidening?
- Stupidening, I like it.
- Of everyone, basically.
- Absolutely.
But DeSantis manages
to get past that.
He manages to outtalk
"The View", right?
I think that that's the case.
- When given the opportunity.
So, I think DeSantis
handles it very well,
and I think it was MSNBC
asked his office for a comment
and they said, "We will
not be commenting."
- Yeah, that was after the
Andrea Mitchell, absolute lie.
Why does Ron DeSantis
not wanna teach slavery?
The reason I'm asking that
question though is because
there was the book that was
taken out so far, the only book,
what was it?
It was the gender, what was it?
"Woke Gender Theory"?
- I don't remember, I don't
know what it was called.
- But they were
literally teaching kids
how to give hand jobs.
Why would you want
that in a school?
I mean, do you guys ever
talk to these people?
Were you able to
whittle it down to that
with any of the people
that you're fighting with?
They have the grand woke idea,
but do you ever get it
to them in that node.
- We have a chapter
on sexuality.
- I mean, at the end of the day,
all parents are bigots
and not woke enough.
And it is their job, it
is their sacred duty,
to save our children
from their parents.
- I mean, that's Communism 101.
You know a bit about this.
- First chapter, yeah.
But the thing is that they're
also not having children.
They want to indoctrinate
our children,
they're not having any.
- Yeah, they're
all antinatalists.
- Yeah, their fertility
rates are really low.
So it ends up happening
that they don't have kids
and they want your kids
to have this information.
And the thing is, the secrecy
is such a big part of it.
They don't run on, you know,
"Let's get porn into schools."
They run on,
"Oh, we're going to have
great books in our library."
But then they end up
having stuff like that.
- What is going on with
whether these teachers
are actually dealt with or not.
So when Libs of TikTok
puts up these videos
of these teachers,
and they clearly are
saying exactly what you said,
they say it themselves,
"These are our kids."
They view themselves as the
savior of these children.
Are they being fired?
I know in Florida a
couple of them have.
- Florida.
- I'm guessing in
Montgomery County
- Yeah, I'm telling you.
it's probably not happening.
- So, in that regard
it's still strengthening
in some respects.
- Yeah, no.
I mean, it is part of the
job description to be woke.
I mean, the number of
teachers that I've heard from
who say, "I am not comfortable
and I don't know what to do."
That's, to me, some of the most
discouraging stuff because,
what can they do?
I don't want them to quit.
I don't want everyone to
be insane in these schools.
But, they have to sort of
abide by the superintendent,
the principal, the
curriculum developers.
And so they're really stuck
between a rock and a hard place.
And they feel this
obligation to students,
but they know that it's a
David and Goliath fight.
- "Gender Queer", by the
way, is the name of the book.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah, right.
- That's the main one
that has been taken out
of the Florida schools.
So while the media's
running around saying,
"1.5 million books have been
taken out of Florida schools.",
it's all complete nonsense.
What about at the race level?
'Cause we've talked about it
sort of at the Covid level
and a bit at the gender
and sexuality level.
What's going on
at the race level?
Your kids are
White supremacists.
- They are.
- It's fair to say.
- Well, they're Jews,
so it's not clear.
- No, that's double
White supremacists.
- I dunno if they're
White right now or not.
It's like, you know,
it just depends.
- It depends on the week.
- Yeah, it really does
depend on the week.
The funny thing is that
CRT was somewhat beat back.
That really hit when everybody
was paying attention.
And when CRT, the concept of
it was introduced to parents,
they saw how noxious it was.
And I think that it
provides kind of a roadmap
of what to do.
And the parents should emulate
that in the gender fight.
It's a very similar struggle.
- I mean, I think a
lot of parents of color
also were horrified by CRT.
- Exactly.
- And that was a really powerful
voice because they said,
"Do not teach my children
that they are victims.
Do not teach my children that
we have to lower standards
so that they can succeed.
My child can succeed against
anyone in your school,
and please stop telling
them otherwise."
We wanna talk about racism,
the racism of low expectations
is really what's
harming those kids.
And so those voices
of Black parents
were really, really powerful
in the fight against CRT.
But I think also with
the gender stuff,
it's a lot harder
to speak up because
it's all sort of lumped together
and you're just a
generalized bigot.
Which, I mean, people are.
- That could be the
title of my next book.
- [Both] Generalized Bigot.
- That's pretty good.
Particularly, there's
something about the way
you said bigot that seemed
particularly strong there.
I mean, to some
extent, it's growing.
People are fighting back.
Does this just leave us in
what we've come to
the conclusion of
that it's just the state
and the local community
and lower and lower and lower.
Is there any hope
at the federal level
that any of this will change?
- Well, I don't know
that there's hope for the
government to do anything,
but I do think the
pendulum is swinging
and that parents,
even in blue areas,
kind of had enough of all this.
And it's partly because their
test scores are plummeting,
and they see that their kids
are not learning anything.
- Even the delayed speech
thing, which is huge now!
- Oh it's huge.
- We talk about that a lot.
- It seems like
almost every kid now,
obviously that's a bit
of an exaggeration,
but has some level
of speech deficiency.
That simply was not the
way it was back in the day.
- No, I mean, I've spoken to
speech language pathologists.
My older two kids
were speech delayed,
my nine and my seven year old.
And so I knew immediately
when we started putting masks,
both on kids but also on
their childcare providers,
that this was
going to end badly.
And it's not just that,
but it's also the reading.
I have a kindergartner who
I'm teaching how to read
and I was teaching him
something recently,
oh, it was the word Black,
which is funny enough
since I'm a racist also.
And so, he could
not figure it out.
And I said, "Watch my lips: Ba."
And then as soon as my
lips went between my teeth
he said, "L."
How were they teaching
reading for two years?
And so, I think that
being lied to and told
that the sky isn't
blue so many times
really sort of woke
a lot of parents up.
But, the level of delays,
I think we're only just
starting to realize.
And I've seen data from
speech language pathologists
that like, we're in
for a rough road.
And if there's any of
your viewers out there
who are in college thinking
about their future life plans,
child psychologists, speech
language pathologists,
occupational therapists,
very safe jobs.
- Yeah.
How worried are you that,
I don't know that you
cover this in the book,
but that this generation
of kids is gonna grow up
and really do horrible things
to their parents in some ways?
I really mean it.
- I hope they do.
- Literally, when they're
checking them into the home
being like, "No, no, you're
going to the cheaper home."
And that at some point
they'll realize, you know,
because they were
also drugged probably,
on prescription drugs
and not going to school
and masks on the face.
You even see it
now at the airport.
You'll see parents without masks
and they've still got
the kids in the masks.
I actually think
there is going to be
a real generational thing there.
- I mean, that's
if it doesn't take,
if it's not like those kids
are doing the same thing
to their kids, which would be
one of the better case
scenarios, I think.
Not that I'm saying anybody
should be throwing anybody
in a home or anything like that.
- I have six kids,
I'm probably safe.
- Probably.
- But you just need one
that's gonna take
decent care of you.
- The odds are
really in my favor.
- You're gonna be fine.
What else are you
guys hitting in here?
Okay, so we've got
gender, we've got Covid,
we've got race stuff.
The sort of move to where
you're supposed to be
kind of thing.
- Yeah, the medical
chapter was huge.
- The medical chapter.
The history chapter that
we open with, I think,
will be eye-opening for people.
I don't think they
think about it as
something that has
happened in history before.
It's not new.
This indoctrination thing,
they do this to kids in
totalitarian societies.
And we happen to be going
through a very similar period.
I would say that throughout my
life people have said to me,
because I was born
in the Soviet Union,
"Do you feel like
this is very Soviet?"
And I would always
say, "No, no."
You know, the Clinton years,
no, they don't feel
very Soviet to me.
But this does.
And the way that people told
on each other during Covid,
neighbors calling the
police on each other,
the way that they socially
pressured each other
to only have a very
narrow set of opinions,
"If you think
schools should open,
that means you want
teachers to die.",
and that sort of thing,
it was very reminiscent of
the stories of my youth.
The things that my grandmother
would tell me about
your friends turning on you
because you weren't
politically correct.
And, it's scary.
- Did this change how you guys
do family structure
things as well?
Because they're obviously
trying to infiltrate the family.
Did it shift anything in
terms of how you deal with,
or just your internal,
literally, your home?
So, when I was
writing the chapter on
entertainment and media,
I spent a lot of time on
literature because I think that
folks are now pretty
understanding of the fact that
when they turn on the TV,
Disney, everything is woke.
But, the insidiousness of it
in the children's literature
space I think is very shocking.
And I was talking to
two mothers one week
and both of them
mentioned the same book,
a graphic novel for
middle grade kids.
So like, hmm, 7 to 12 or so.
And it's for girls, and it's
about girl soccer players.
And both of them told me
there's a sex scene in it
between two girls
at a sleepover.
And I was like, "I
don't want my daughter
thinking she can have a sexual
encounter at a sleepover."
That seems like a road
that I don't wanna open.
The second time the mother
described it in more detail,
I thought, "Girl, soccer
player, graphic novel.
What did we pick up at
the library last week?
I feel like that
sounds familiar."
And I hung up the phone, got
my iPhone flashlight out,
opened my trunk, went into the
bag with the library books,
and there it was.
And I said, "Oh, well I
could quote this extensively
'cause my daughter picked it
out at the library this week."
And I hadn't brought
the book in, and I said,
"That's it for us
at the library.
I'm done."
And it was ironic because
I spent all of Covid
fighting with my local
library to reopen,
I don't remember the last
time I've been there.
- Isn't it weird how
it ultimately became
a war on normalcy?
Remember when Megyn
Kelly finally had her
final straw with all this
after they were doing all of
this stuff at her kid's school
on the upper West side.
And then she took a picture,
I think, of a bookstore
that I used to live
a block away from
on Amsterdam and 83rd,
it was literally like woke
superheroes or something
in the bookstore window.
And then she was like, "Okay,
I gotta leave this city."
Like, that they just everywhere.
- That's really what it was.
It was the war on normalcy,
that's what drove
us out of New York.
It was that we didn't see
normalcy returning for a while,
and childhoods very short.
So we didn't want our kids
to be growing up in that.
And I think that's
the real thing
parents need to give their kids,
that stability and normalcy
so that they grow up
and they're resilient.
And that's the goal,
raising resilient children.
- Yeah.
- Well, Bethany, you walked
in here with a two-month-old
who then you handed
to my assistant.
We haven't heard anything
in the last 40 minutes,
so I feel like it's probably
going okay out there.
- Fingers crossed.
Or she's taken him, in which
case, I have five spares.
So, good luck to her.
- Any final thoughts, ladies?
We will link to
the book down below
and we'll do our best
to get you on the
"New York Times"
Bestseller List.
But of course, you know,
that's completely made up
because they're woke and
they are not big fans.
- Greta Thunbergs at the top.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Well, that's the thing
that really people
should understand
is that this has
permeated everything.
You think that something is
normal or fair or standard,
and it's not.
And "New York Times"
Bestseller List
is a great example of that where
it doesn't matter how
many books you sell,
the Greta Thunberg example,
she was on the bestseller list
last week with 4,000 books.
I'm sure that you sold more.
- I sold way more.
- Way more, and you were not.
- I should have been
number two, possibly number
one for my last book.
They didn't even put me on it.
And on my first book
they put me at 11
when I should have been four.
- That's really
what we're fighting.
- And I sold 10 times
more than number four.
- That's what we're
fighting here.
It's that this abnormal behavior
and this push of
just one viewpoint
is permeating everything,
and you have to keep
your kids from it.
- Yeah.
I mean, the final thought for
me is the resilience chapter.
That was the last
chapter that I wrote
and told a very personal
story of my mom passing away
and the circumstances of
that when I was 16 years old.
I was the one that pulled
the plug, spoiler alert,
and I was raised resilient.
And I went to a therapist
who gave me some tough love
and said, "Do not define
yourself as a victim.
If it's not who you want to be,
do not define yourself as such."
What are the chances of a
16 year old Bethany today
having a therapist who
would say that to her?
Now victimhood is the goal.
It's not something
that you wanna avoid.
And it's creating a
generation of children
who are not just not resilient,
but who are basket cases.
And that's the goal.
- Alright.
Well to end this, we
can reveal our plan now.
You guys went through
this whole process
of writing this whole
book, coming here,
et cetera, et cetera,
but it was really,
should we hold her
hand while we say it?
- Yeah, you're gonna
live in Florida now.
- It was to move you to Florida.
- With my one suitcase
and my two-month-old. (laughs)
- You're staying.
There is no flight back, and
your child has been taken
by my assistant.
(all laughing)
It's been a pleasure, ladies.
- It was really nice.
- The book is "Stolen Youth".
The link is right down below.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.